bientôt c'est squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur fly and out voilà le futur
blockbuster type que tout le monde
possédera en 2016 donc à un mode
histoire et un mode arcade apparemment
pour un jeu où le but est d'écraser les
mouches quand même fort je suis rentré
chez moi ma maison est vide et j'ai pas
vu ma famille depuis longtemps à mon
dieu qu'est ce que c'est que ce bruit en
eau olhao la bh bien là j'arrive à
piquer [ __ ] aulas talk un banquet
hopla bientôt est chaude hp fait face
des combos et tous pour des bouquets
level 2 quoi sans déconner a marqué deux
buts c'est tout cas c'est quoi pouvoir
des points c'est génial carla et sa
patte gauche de drm [ __ ] de fourmies
t-ball quoi tient géré espèce de vieille
mère voilà pourquoi j'ai pas de
nouvelles de encore là à temps et c'est
beaucoup trop et on se débloque
estevelles temps dégagé tout péter dans
la maison quelque chose de plus
alors comment au hockey on peut lancer
des trucs déjà cei ne l'ont pas dit ça
les bouverans voilà là on fait des
combos 15 plein de trucs c'est cool tu
as le mec il a fait que trois niveaux du
coup les apaches pour rentabiliser quoi
pour accéder au level 2 il faut
franchement vos deux heures de jeu quoi
qu'ils accueillaient c'est la branche
juge d'emprunt de cinq agents à part toi
pour débloquer un level quoi je le fais
tu n'appelles là haut non [ __ ] de quoi
elle est là elle peut pas se barrer
juste elle m'a enfermée quoi je pourrais
pas ouvert la porte cette plaque jaune
mais [ __ ] mais je passe encore plus
haut dans la vraie vie je m'impatiente
l'a bien viens là vient là vient la
maison mais là bas mais attends mais
attend lé champion de ski vont au
mondial quoi sans déconner philosophie
de l'esquif sur la petite arctique au
volant elle s'est en fait à la hockey à
quel moment tu perds quand elle par quoi
on compte assez content mais je réussis
à débloquer ce niveau-là chantera pète
un câble un jour on doit tuer une mouche
bordel vient la viande achetée grâce
avec un plateau salle hop hop ways pas
sauvés par le gong mais sauvé par le
lustre quoi mais ce jus puis dire que
blood bord didar souffle sans déconner
quoi ok le vase de base à marcher elle
va se souvenant de la vaseline excellent
cela sape a marché écoute je sers un
petit matignon on arrête tout ok et tu
me débloque le niveau de sa devint
téléphone
[ __ ] fils de mots je peux tomber vers
la ramène je suis honoré du bruit d'une
mouette psp tout l'effet escompté ok
mais d'où elle a cassé la planche
carrément la nouvelle fait du karaté en
plus de ça cette mouche la lapointe la
poêle à bois et ça c'est un bon plan
saas comme une [ __ ] à mouches un peu
plus violents on va la faire cuire on va
brûler dit elle est où la mouche c'est
parti en de la maison c'est un supporter
a en fait pour du lauquet niveau de il
faut réussir tous ces trucs là non plus
au score c'est sur 83 il faut faire
mille
donc c'est vraiment d'arc mouche de
houmous soultz de houblon
mouche ou mouche bornes où je me rends
très bien bref c'est aussi dur que
darche vous éblouit bornes sont en train
de péter un câble bordel oh non mais là
attendez avec mon expérience de sniper
mlg pro nos scoops quoi j'étais avec mon
dos c'est scandaleux c'est en train de
vous parler tout en reculant et un plat
mouche est mort à tort juste avant je
lui lance des planches en bois et un
frigo et elle meurt pas quoi j'avais que
41 points quoi la tuile en soi un cousin
très la pièce ça donne pas plus de
points coûté un moment va jouer au mode
arcade au plus tard la voilà là on est
dans le nord il ya plein de mouchan ça
ça fait de la pub difficulté ça
attendons et un gros revers lui nous
tondent hammouche quoi le triture
facilite ap n ya pas de musique c'est
interdit la musique le soir un au rayon
va l'étouffer vivante
je suis au nom y est bien sûr une mouche
qui arrive c'est ça ta voilà qu'est ce
tu dit ça fdp
les nouvelles mouche moi je m'en bats
les steaks de la défonce atys merde
gilles pitet lumière ce n'est pas ce que
je voulais faire une blague à steinbach
secteur tout ce que vous pouvez faire
tient chaud mais je suis au toit devient
hyper tendus sur un jeu de mouches c'est
pas bien regardé à bien de me coller en
plus et si je mets flash lite avec acura
six ans [ __ ] c'est carrément dit on
regarde a vraiment une langue à toulon
monseigneur pas arrivées pour nous aider
à péter la mouche
mais acura game over il faut pas m'aider
d'objets confère un statut je fais comme
si le tnf k et d'un coup
merde à tanger fait-on bas tableau mon
gars moi il soulage beaucoup n'ont fait
pas ça on me dit pas non fait plaisir
non mais j'irai sur le mode c'est ça je
ne peux pas de paris siens dans tous les
modes sur un chauffe-eau but et une
mouche quoi
tous dans la simplicité ok pour
débloquer le niveau suivant il faut
réussir chaque défi d'arcade par exemple
d'en tuer plusieurs manches dont tu es 3
facile facile à temps mais les nouvelles
sur le toit la mouche et sur le toit
comment je la tue bordel comment je la
tue elle est elle au dessus fait partie
des experts des bouchoux elle pas
traverser les murs je prends pour des
galères à les écraser après s'être hertz
les murs des futurs hommes
ça va pas nous aider un c'est drôle à
eau
ohlala et voilà c'est la fin mais on a
pété 5 mouche donc finalement logique à
toiture pas le niveau 2 mais non il faut
qu'on fasse la destruction rapide joue
ma vie dans un jeu de mouches
ok foutu et la mouche en vingt secondes
en fait ok défi relevé pourquoi se
débloquer ah ouais [ __ ] il faut faire
un score de plus de 1000 à la paire les
gens je suis déchaînez la soie train to
p t on à 664 il ne manque 40 on est bon
je n'épargnerai aucun objet aux mondiaux
d'affilée mais il faut juste but est la
bouche
oui tiens dans le coin comme ça là et là
mais non complet complet complet complet
mais ils tous pas je fais 1175 mais je
m'en fous je m'en fous de bach cédé au
deuxième niveau je m'en fous matt ma vie
se résume pas tuer une mouche dans un
jeu vidéo bordel ça rend violent plus
ces jeux vidéo c'est pour les cons et
jeux vidéo enrichie et ben voilà les
gens c'est avec une grande déception que
je vous annonce la fin c'était field et
aux besoins des connecteurs n'a fait
depuis objectif en parrain je me suis
pas vu l'âge mais pendant pendant 45
minutes un jour tu des mouches adibou il
a toi giallo moi je vous le dis mais
c'est pas m dos et vous a plu si vous en
voulez plus c'est une blague jamais y
aura plus de ce jeu bah ça vous regarde
on s'est retrouvé à terre dans une
prochaine vidéo tient tout le monde pis
oui bonjour j'aimerais rencontrer les
filles hot de ma région
cela représente un bon jour où puis je
rencontrais l'une de ses fans